la rentrée scolaire commence
progressivement en espagne et c'est une
rentrée des classes qui se rassure
indique le gouvernement espagnol
alors mes dates de rentrée varices dans
chaque région c'est à chaque communauté
autonome de mettre en place ses propres
restrictions alors globalement le port
du masque est obligatoire à partir de
l'âge de 6 ou 12 ans le nombre d'élèves
par classe est limité un lavage des
mains régulier est assurée et la
distance sociale également alors chaque
établissement un centre de santé de
référence pour être accompagnées dans le
protocole en cas de personnes positives
dans l'établissement si une personne est
positive toute la classe devrait être en
quarantaine alors pour veiller au
respect de ces mesures de sécurité les
inspections techniques vont être
réalisés dans chaque établissement alors
à madrid des milliers de professeurs et
directeurs doivent se soumettre à des
tests sérologiques provoquant de longues
files d'attentes dans la capitale en
catalogne ce sont 500 mille tests qui
sont prévues jusqu'en novembre
l'inquiétude continue d'être réel pour
les professeurs qui se demandent quel
sera le protocole en cas de
contamination dans l'établissement mais
aussi sur comment vont s'organiser les
cours dans les établissements ou de
petite taille et pour les étudiants
toutes ces conditions de rentrée ne sont
pas suffisantes il convoque donc une
grève
les 16 17 et 18 septembre prochain pour
protester